hot breath how long did it take you to
get to that point well you know here it
took me
longer because i had more responsibility
i mean
it was just me in a one bedroom i could
have done it
forever true you know once you get a hot
you know a house and a mortgage and a
family and blah blah blah it's like
certain gives you like i gotta take this
gig
i gotta go take the hit but then there's
a point where you're like um i just
can't do it anymore because
my soul hurts too much you know and
you're
i'm not funny here
this isn't one this isn't about funny
this is about
selling chicken wings or some and
nobody here can't cares about stand-up
comedy
that's why i love the comedy seller they
care so much
about the comics performing at their
peak level
you know that you can't talk you can't
yell out
there is no check spot there is no
you don't have your phone they make you
put it in a bag oh okay
if you if you take if you're seeing with
the phone you're immediately tossed
you're not asked to put it away you're
gone
that's saying our comics
are very important
and them being comfortable is very
important for them
to perform at the best level they can
possibly perform at
and it's so true and and i work clubs
that
do that now you know so i'm happy about
i mean look at some clubs that i work
like side splitters in tampa
i mean it's a it's like the wild
west but i kind of like that
i love those fans down there
mm-hmm you know because they're
crazy
but you have fans you know like it's
people come to see you now
yeah but i'm one of those guys who had
to turn over turn over every single rock
on the beach looking for them
oh really how'd you find them you still
have to
you know i have to find my fans
i have to get them
some people are just giving fans you
know there's some comics that are
literally just given a fan base
and it's just like wow i've been
for 20 something years
building a fan base of people who like
my
and uh and that's that's who they are
and they're the best
they come and see me five six times yeah
that's great how can comics start to
build a fan base
what kind of tips do you have for that
well i don't know man it's you know it's
it's weird it's like
you know you can get a mailing list you
can sit offside and
you know get everybody to sign up on
your mailing list and you know you can
do all this
i just don't know
i don't know man i don't know
some people get one little tiny show on
this whatever network and they're famous
you know i mean look at girl code
a few years ago five years ago
those girls were like you know openers
emcees at comedy clubs
and they did a little
show on on vh1
and because was it mtv right tv yeah i
didn't watch
tv and they're selling out theaters